[Musique]
je
leur choux fleurs
jo
fleurs ok je commence
je choisis marine en quoi c'est quoi ces
rires non non je croyais que tu pouvais
pas la blairer apparemment ça a changé
il a dit quoi il dit rien du tout alors
à toi annonce que je vais prendre pjak
est doux pierrick fay un collègue de
capotes peut-être pas au courant la
soirée du 31 on a passé un super moment
du coup je prends avec moi et bas dans
ce cas je vais prendre aurélien
sérieuses questions
tout ça pour elle c'est mon pote
d'enfance tu voulais jamais qui viennent
à l'appart est là maintenant tu le
prends dans ton équipe
écoutez generis ouais d'accord c'est
juste qu'on cherchait ouais c'est la
première de mes raisons mais c'est
vraiment c'est moi qui suis pas sympa
assez marrant parce que je pensais que
c'était largué sa meuf la veille de son
anniversaire qui était pas certain
j'avais oublié que c'était son
anniversaire et ses os moi je fais un
pitch schilb et mon anniv mais ça à ce
bon pote silence bastien vous fait
plaisir là oui mais plus tard d'un me
soutiennent on est quand même bon qu'un
pas oui enfin on est surtout bon voisin
tu fais quoi là papa bah je sais pas je
me disais qu'on pourrait se refaire
quelques petites soirées ligue des
champions on se marrait bien quoi papa
tu reviens aux quais bas dans ce cas moi
je récupère mon pote beauté alors je
récupère ton style quand on fait
rencontrer tu te fera guincher goélands
bastien tu récupères ton pote je
récupère ton style
m.ban l'idée de ouf là je te vois comme
ça on devrait refaire notre groupe de
ska babylone bavella venez certains vous
avez déjà commencé
qu'est-ce qu'il est bas j'ai appris que
vous vouliez plus ensemble donc je me
suis dit que c'était le bon moment pour
faire mon come back dis donc t'as pas
cent étant juste un gros elle est
toujours aussi bonne mais je veux jouer
avec moi mais non c'est refusé de venir
avec monsieur ou alors tu sais ce que je
veux faire je vais prendre emma et je
vais la mettre sur mon héros plastique
fais ce que tu veux bastien je m'en fous
ok ça va te braque pas ce que j'ai dit
quelque chose moi quand etienne il a
voulu intégrer son équipe
non mais c'est quoi le rapport avec les
tiers mais regarde le regarde sa tête là
il veut jouer avec toi depuis le début
pas du tout très drôle moi je suis là
parce qu'on va appeler il n'y a pas de
ses pertes depuis le début je te dis que
c'est une planche pour y semer un gros
tas dit quoi là non mais tu me le dis on
a une bonne assise dans sa gueule c'est
terminé j'ai toujours pas l'équipe s'il
faut moi je me défonce ton mec ok je
vais à la salle superbe a réussi à
baston générale veut me battrai pas
contre la demoiselle qui est là parce
que je la trouve très jolie
ouais donc ça tu es en roue libre totale
quoi tu dragues devant ta fille y'a rien
qui chuck drague pas vos compliments
ces compléments de sava meilhan est
complètement en fait non mais c'est très
gentil monsieur mais en fait j'ai une
règle je couche pas avec le père de l'ex
de mon ex est très spécifique stop
hockey n'était pas une bonne idée en
fait si tu sais quoi on va le faire ce
match on va jouer maintenant
suis-tu la chanson c'est un connard ses
vrais connards et surtout mes filles ap
on en a ras la casquette est dispo ya
moi on les aime bien malgré tout je suis
mieux vaut les aces et une [ __ ] elle
tentant je vais te laisser dans ton
équipe
non mais moi ça me fait plaisir de voir
la formation des zayanes 88
tu te souviens au nom du groupe
je me souviens même de la chanson que tu
m'avais écrite
ah ouais
sps c'était le début que ce n'était pas
mais
et tu crois pas que ça va me faire
bizarre de rejouer après tant d'années
on va essayer au match
[Musique]